[Musique]
aujourd'hui beaucoup de jeunes ne savent
rien sur julian assange ou survie qu'il
x sinon tu connais julian assange ne
sais-tu quelque chose à son sujet et sur
ce qui lui est arrivé peut-être non tu
veut en apprendre plus à son sujet bien
sûr il y a dix ans le site wikileaks a
rendu publique une grande quantité
d'informations sur les crimes commis par
les gouvernements des pays occidentaux
ouest essentiellement des crimes de
guerre pour la plupart connus par le
gouvernement américain
il s'agit notamment de meurtres de
civils innocents dans les pays étrangers
à les feux continuent à tirer
autrefois on pouvait faire semblant de
ne pas savoir c'est ça la chose la plus
fascinante à propos de wikileaks il nous
oblige en quelque sorte à le reconnaître
et nous ne pouvons plus ignorer tout ça
continue à tirer c'est un idéaliste et
là une mission les ailes mais sa mission
est de donner aux gens des informations
à wikileaks oeuvre de toute évidence
pour l'audience car mais ceci a un prix
depuis combien de temps est-il en prison
il a passé sept ou huit ans à
l'ambassade de l'équateur
il est en détention depuis très très
longtemps et cela fait désormais
plusieurs mois déjà qu'il se trouve à la
prison de belmarsh hyper matches plus un
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens veulent qu'il reste en
prison beaucoup de gens très influents
est ce département mène une très active
et très méticuleux enquête visant à
déterminer comment cette fuite a eu lieu
à identifier la personne ou les
personnes qui en sont responsables
a lancé je ne veux pas le voir mourir
dans une prison américaine
et je crois que c'est le sort qui
l'attend et swing mais tout ce qu'ils
voulaient faire c'est rendre le monde
meilleur
oui c'est ça y'a pas de raison de penser
que ce n'est pas ce qu'ils cherchent à
faire et il cherche à révéler des crimes
que nos gouvernements comme est
prétendument pour notre bien
[Musique]
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse vraiment
comprendre julien assange de wikileaks
sans avoir pris connaissance dans
certains aspects de sa vie qui a
beaucoup participé à sa formation
et cela s'est passé ici à melbourne non
seulement à l'origine de ces idées de sa
personnalité de sa vision mais aussi de
son approche conceptuelle des projets
logiciels dont wikileaks
à la fin des années 80 et au début des
années 90 melbourne était le centre
informatique australien est aussi
international qui comprenait des
expérimentateurs et des hackers les gens
qui piratent et et qui faisait toutes
sortes d'expériences
il n'a pas fallu longtemps aux jeunes
julian assange pour s'intégrer dans la
communauté des hackers australien
adolescent il passait la plupart de leur
temps connecté
mais de temps à autres lorsqu'ils
sortaient ils se réunissaient sur cette
place au centre de melbourne fait
l'hôtel de ville de filtres oeil et
c'était là avec quelques autres hôtels
de ville de melbourne qui était
organisée des marchés aux puces
julien assange et d'autres membres de
cette communauté qui avait la vingtaine
ou même pas encore gagné ici acheter des
équipements et échanger des idées des
informations sur les ordinateurs et
logiciels
[Musique]
dès son plus jeune âge il faisait partie
de la première vague de jeunes qui
voulaient s'y connaître en informatique
cela convenait bien ses capacités
organisationnelles et sa patience à sa
curiosité à son excellente mémoire et à
la compréhension de la programmation
comme putté
je n'avais pas prévu qu'il deviendra
célèbre dans le monde entier si vite
qu'il serait à la tête de l'une des plus
puissantes organisations médiatiques du
monde à mu
est la mentalité des hackers de l'époque
était très intéressante
il cherchait l'excitation dans le fait
de pénétrer dans des systèmes dont
l'accès était interdit et plus
l'institution était prestigieuse plus
elle était excitante
s'ils pouvaient piraté l'ordinateur de
la nasa je veux dire on parle là des
gens les plus intelligents monde des
gens qui ont envoyé l'homme sur la lune
vraiment si vous pouviez vous introduire
dans leur système
ça prouve et que pour quelqu'un de 17
ans vous étiez un jeune homme très
intelligent de yooz l'agencé spatiale
américaine nasa a été l'une des victimes
d'un groupe de hackers de melbourne les
inquiéter américains parmi lesquels des
agents du fbi ont contacté les autorités
australiennes
le 16 octobre 1989 le réseau
informatique de la nasa a été piraté à
l'aide du virus ou anc
en conséquence le lancement d'une
navette spatiale à florida a été reporté
la cyberattaque a été attribuée aux
hackers de melbourne a été l'un des
premiers virus ondes et c'est
certainement le premier virus à
motivation politique
le premier qui diffusait un message
politique c'était une citation de la
chanson de midnight oil qui dit vous
parlez d'une ère de paix pour tout le
monde mais vous vous préparez à la
guerre
[Musique]
et
vers où on a surgit des profondeurs des
forêts obscures vous aviez un aperçu
puis disparaît c ils n'auront jamais
trouver les auteurs
d'ailleurs certains estiment que c'était
là l'une des premières créations de
julian assange
il existe beaucoup d'opinions
différentes à ce sujet
[Musique]
julian a eu la chance de grandir dans
une famille modeste sur le plan
économique que nos mac mais
intellectuellement très riche entre
axway le père de julian est un homme
très intelligent et créatif mais aussi
assez sensible vraiment une personne
sensible
je crois qu'il a joué un rôle
extrêmement important dans sa formation
en tant que jeune adulte allante sa
julienne et est un jeune homme
remarquable son surnom était le magicien
parce qu'il était toujours capable
d'élaborer une nouvelle approche de voir
les choses autrement
coup de coeur me disais qu une vision
totalement différente du monde prenait
forme à partir du système qu'ils avaient
pénétré
est ce parce qu'ils avaient ainsi accès
aux données réelles et elles sont
souvent à l'opposé de ce qu une
organisation ou un homme politique peut
déclarer publiquement
ils comprennent que ça me convient au
public que ce n'est pas seulement un
petit mensonge mais bien souvent un très
grand mensonge c'est sans doute comme ça
que julian a développé l'idée selon
laquelle il était important pour les
organisations médiatiques de fournir des
informations précises
[Musique]
julienne était chez moi et nous prenions
le thé je crois que je ne suis pas sûr
c'était en 2006 quelque chose comme ça
assez tôt en tout cas et jolie anne m'a
dit qu'il voulait lancer un site wiki et
que ce wiki concernerait les fuites et
que les gens qui voudraient divulguer
des informations pour qu'elles soient
rendues publiques utiliserait tort avez
vous essayé de le mettre en garde à ce
moment là
non pourquoi c'était un jeune homme avec
toute la vie devant lui
on ne donne pas d'avertissement à
quelqu'un comme lui on lui demande
comment puis-je td j'ai toujours pris à
coeur cette métaphore de la nature vit
dangereusement
davy dangereusement dans le clip ne
tourne pas autour du pot n'ai pas peur
de l'ombre fais ce que tu as à faire et
affrontent les conséquences du mieux
possible
c'est cette ligne de conduite qui m'a
guidé toute ma vie pour moi
là
mathieu lievin sort
[Musique]
au total 2,6 crazy horse invite nous
avons ici six personnes avec des fusils
ak 47 demandes d'autorisations
d'engagement bien reçu aucun des nôtres
à l'aise de notre opposition
donc vous pouvez y aller terminer j'ai
entendu parler de wikileaks et de julian
assange pour la première fois quand j'ai
vu les images filmées depuis
l'hélicoptère en irak
la fameuse vidéo où l'hélicoptère tire
sur des gens au sol
allez on est tous allés feu continue à
tirer continue à tirer continue à tirer
quand l'hélicoptère a tiré sur des
civils et sur deux journalistes de
reuters
deux journalistes locaux de reuters il a
également tiré sur quelques enfants qui
étaient dans une voiture
nous avons un tas de corps là à peu près
vu personne oui il ya un type qui
rampent là-bas mais on a bien vu quelque
chose
anthian offres reçues les militaires
américains ont pris des civils pour des
rebelles ils ont cru depuis leur
hélicoptère que l'un des hommes avaient
une arme à feu alors que ce n'était
qu'un caméraman de reuters tenant un
téléobjectif
[Musique]
je n'oublierai jamais le jour où j'ai vu
cette vidéo je ne l'oublierai jamais
parce que c'était la première fois que
je criais aussi fort au bureau
ces soldes agissent avec une telle
indifférence émotionnelle d'état comme
s'ils jouaient à des jeux vidéo ôtant la
vie à ces gens pleins de vie avec une
telle indifférence in such as khroub
ces salles où sont morts il a joué et
voilà donc on a une vidéo bien réel info
de choquant
un fait est le preuve irréfutable de ce
qui s'est passé
comme me l'a dit un militaire à la
retraite ici en australie
il ne fait aucun doute que c'est un
crime de guerre
le lendemain après les tirs du 13
juillet 2007 le commandement militaire
américain a justifié la tacc en
expliquant que ces militaires s'étaient
retrouvés dans un combat avec des forces
hostiles les corps
parmi les blessés il y avait deux
enfants il était dans le camion quand
leur père s'est approché du lieu de la
fusillade pour aider les victimes
bushmaster crazy horse des individus
s'approche apparemment pour ramasser les
corps et les armes allaient feu
s'ébauche pasteur cette brosse yeux les
y invite
allez-y c'est dégagé allez c'est dégagé
dégagé
ce qui m'a vraiment surprise c'est quand
j'ai vu une interview d'un soldat
américain qui étaient là à cet endroit a
pris qui leur ont tiré dessus et qui les
ont tués qui ont damé le chanteur
[Musique]
s'était d'un jeune officier de l'armée
qui s'est approché de camions qu'il a
découvert deux enfants blessés
les sabres il a expliqué que la petite
fille ne pouvait pas cligner des yeux
parce qu'ils étaient plein d'éclats de
verre alors il a essayé de retirer le
verre des yeux de la boutique lorsqu'il
a parlé à son supérieur a expliqué
vouloir amener la petite dans un hôpital
d'essen on lui a répondu a fait pas des
gonzesses
il faut être plus dur c'est de leur
faute d'avoir emmené les enfants sur un
lieu de combat exactement pour la
première fois nous avons compris que
c'étaient des pertes civiles que des
innocents ont été tués en afghanistan et
en irak a
ânesse raison est que tout cela était
cachée au public julian assange a fait
preuve de beaucoup de courage en
acceptant de publier sans hésitation et
sans crainte cette vidéo et je pense
qu'il ya des gens dans l'armée
américaine qui ne lui ont jamais
pardonné
cette attaque d'hélicoptère a fait entre
12 et 18 morts deux enfants ont été
blessés
aucun militaire américain n'en a jamais
été tenus responsables après cette vidéo
julian assange a dévoilé son identité
est devenu célèbre
c'était à la une des journaux du monde
entier à ce moment là non seulement
julian assange se retrouvait sous le feu
des projecteurs mais il avait trouvé un
moyen de publier des informations
classées secrètes et les a mises à
disposition de tous
[Musique]
l'idée de développer une boîte de dépôts
numériques anonyme en lien avec le média
qu'est wikileaks
c'est une vraie nouveauté personne
n'avait vraiment fait ça avant c'est
julian assange qui l'a fait cela a
permis aux lanceurs d'alert de mettre en
lumière certains faits de manière
anonyme et à très faible coût en
transmettant d'importants volumes de
données avec une simple connexion
aujourd'hui nous publions plus de 287
fichiers documents tant la réalité de
l'industrie internationale de
surveillance de masse qui est d'entre
eux voient un iphone et un blackberry
qui d'entre vous utilisent le gmail très
bien et bien vous êtes tous foutus puis
je vous demander où tous ces fichiers
sont stockés
je ne sais pas assez dans le cloud
je ne sais pas quelque part
[Musique]
de manière assez magique
julian a réuni les ordinateurs la
numérisation et l'information et les a
mis à la disposition du public sans
encore donc quand quelqu'un se disant
être julian assange a frappé à la porte
du frontline club
j'étais très content de le voir mais
j'étais très enthousiaste à l'idée
d'avoir quelqu'un qui s'occupe est
d'informer je m'appelle vaughan smith
je suis journaliste mais je dirige en
plus le frontline club que j'ai fondées
c'est un club un club social est un club
de presse pour journalistes à londres
tout s'est passé dans cette salle c'est
à dire que julian s'est littéralement
pointer et a frappé à la porte sans
présentation il frappe à la porte soit
deux jours avant cette conférence de
presse en disant je veux une conférence
de presse sur julian assange nous avons
donc organisé la conférence de presse
pour lui c'était un lundi matin il était
debout ici
ici nous avions un podium le podium
était là il était debout ici c'est à cet
endroit qu'il a soulevé la une du
guardian
c'est là que tout a commencé voici le
guardian de ce matin 14 pages consacrées
à notre sujet aussi 17 pages dans le
spiegel
quelques mois seulement après la
publication de la vidéo de l'attak par
hélicoptère contre des civils à bagdad
d'autres révélations ont été faites
il s'agissait cette fois des dossiers
afghan et irakien
[Musique]
les dossiers afghans et irakiens sont
des fichiers confidentiels du pentagone
sur les activités militaires des
américains et de leurs alliés en
afghanistan et en irak
entre 2004 et 2009
il s'agissait de rapports écrits par des
militaires qui pouvait se trouver en
première ligne ou qui patrouillaient la
zone
c'étaient des choses qu'ils avaient vu
auquel il avait été confronté pendant
leur shift 5 ou dans le cadre d'une
patrouille au fond c'était une sorte de
journal de guerre très détaillée écrit
par des américains et des britanniques
mais je n'avais jamais pensé qu'il
pourrait livrer autant d'informations
c'était une énorme base de données peut
causer vos accused à 16 il s'agit de
400000 rapports de terrain confidentiel
établi par l'armée américaine fbi must
c'est la description de la guerre la
plus précise avoir été publiés dans
l'histoire 122 mille civils ont été
victimes de la guerre louis la justice
n'est quasiment pas une rue à bagdad
acteurs ou on n'aurait pas trouvé deux
corps de gens qui ont péri de manière
violente
ce que les dossiers afghan et irakien
nous ont appris les etats-unis et leurs
alliés auraient minimisé le nombre de
victimes civiles des prisonniers de
guerre ont été torturés des membres du
personnel militaire américain ont été
signalées comme étant impliqué dans la
prostitution des mineurs
quand les secrets commencent à être
publiés
le gouvernement commence à perdre le
contrôle de sa version il avait une
version bien préparé en irak
pas de morts parmi les civils et puis
ils ont perdu le contrôle de cette
version parce que nous avons appris la
vérité c'est le pouvoir de wikileaks sur
le terrain les conséquences de la
publication de ces documents pourraient
potentiellement être sérieuse et
dangereuse pour nos troupes nos alliés
et partenaires afghans et pourrait
endommager nos relations et notre
réputation dans cette zone essentielle
de la planète
l'une des principales critiques vous
concernant et que vous avez publié les
noms des villages et dans certains cas
les coordonnées gps d'argan ayant
coopéré avec l'armée américaine
les autorités américaines voient cela
comme une potentielle liste des gens à
battre pour les talibans que le répondu
aux sponsors
la liste est surtout l'objet de
l'exagération des médias nous
envisageons très sérieusement problème
pour savoir si c'est vrai nous avons
demandé à la maison blanche de nous
accorder son assistance pour étudier ces
matériaux avant leurs publications
phares les ils ont refusé
il ne cesse de répéter ils ont du sang
sur leurs mains ils mettent déjà en
danger mais je pense que si quelqu'un
avait été tué à cause de wikileaks il
aurait traîné cette personne devant les
caméras ils auraient mis en évidence
utilisé contre eux sort je pense que
c'est un mensonge flagrant est il
possible de faire en sorte que la
première partie des journaux de guerre
afghans soient mieux expurgés ben oui
elle aurait sans doute pu être mieux
expurgé mais qui avait déjà fait ça
auparavant on avait personne
il n'y avait pas d'instructions julian
assange et wikileaks
avancé comme dans la jungle faut essayer
de comprendre comment procéder
s
les dossiers afghan et irakien ont été
la plus grande fuite de l'histoire
ils ont mis en lumière les crimes de
guerre qui auraient été commis par les
états unis et leurs alliés
aucun militaire américain n'a été tenu
responsable
[Musique]
un peu plus de dix ans j'ai été contacté
par une personne que je ne connaissais
pas du tout à l'époque qui voulait me
rencontrer
je les rencontre et c'était un homme qui
parlait avec un très fort accent
australien et qui m'a dit qu'il avait un
programme un projet qui voulait faire
lorsque nous nous sommes rencontrés au
début j'ai pensé que c'était
complètement farfelu qui n'y avait rien
là dedans
[Musique]
nos chemins se sont séparés mais on est
resté en contact
un peu plus tard la vidéo collatéral
murder a été publié celle où l'on
pouvait voir un hélicoptère américain à
battre des journalistes de reuters en
pleine rue en irak
maintenant j'ai vite compris qu'il était
sérieux à propos de ce projet
julian assange a invité joannes a
travaillé avec lui sur une nouvelle
série de documents confidentiels qui
était tombé entre les mains de wikileaks
cette fois il s'agissait de la
correspondance de la diplomatie
américaine
les télégrammes des diplomates
américains que wikileaks a publié un peu
plus tard constituer une série de
rapports un terme si l'on peut dire où
des analyses que tous les diplomates
américains avaient rédigé et envoyé au
département d'état rod courrier de la
diplomatie américaine publiée le 28
novembre 2010 ils comprennent la
correspondance diplomatique américaine
de 1966 à 2010 cent mille documents
portant la mention confidentiel et 15000
portant la mention secret
nous devons comprendre l'ampleur de ces
informations
si nous prenions ces télégrammes que
nous les imprimons leur longueur
correspondrait à la distance entre saint
pétersbourg et moscou
voilà la quantité de documents que cela
représente je peux vous donner un
exemple simple de ce qui était
intéressant dans ces télégrammes
concernant la suède parce que j'ai
travaillé sur les documents liés à ce
pays
dans ces documents on pouvait voir ce
que des hommes politiques suédois venez
voir l'ambassadeur américain pour lui
demander des services
[Musique]
il disait par exemple nous avons un
problème avec l'opinion publique
suédoise qui n'aime pas la guerre en
afghanistan et ne veut pas que nous
participions à cette guerre pourriez
vous nous aider en invitant des femmes
afghanes à venir en suède pour qu'on
puisse les faire passer à la tv suédoise
afin qu'elle parle de ce que nous
faisons de bien là bas
nous avons soudain découvert que les
hommes politiques et les fonctionnaires
suédois sap et au fonctionnement de la
démocratie suédoise et il agissait ainsi
en collaboration avec les diplomates
américains ce qui est contraire aux
intérêts du peuple suédois pour fait
l'une des choses encourageantes que j'ai
découverte que presque toutes les
guerres de ces 50 dernières années ont
été le résultats de mensonges
médiatiques mais il y aura au total mais
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
cela signifie que les gens ne sont pas
pour les guerres il faut les induire en
erreur pour qu il les accepte échoue il
doit être traité comme un combattant
ennemi
wikileaks doit être définitivement
fermée c'est un traître
il a violé presque toutes les lois
américaines qu'il x fonctionne comment
services de renseignement au stylet
s'exprime comme tel je suis pas pour la
peine de mort et puisque je ne suis pas
pour la peine de mort il n'a qu'une
chose à faire abattre ce fils de petits
légalement julian était au sommet de sa
popularité quand la sphère suédoise est
arrivé le fait est que les femmes
n'étaient pas insensibles
[Musique]
votre actif on peut comprendre qu'il
attirait les jeunes femmes
[Musique]
hier c'est un jeune homme qui avait de
grandes ambitions et de nobles ambitions
ce qui le rendait encore plus attirant
[Musique]
julian assange s'est rendu en suède pour
prononcer un discours
il y a rencontré deux femmes âgées
respectivement de 31 et 26 ans le
fondateur de wikileaks s'est rapidement
retrouvé dans une relation intime avec
chacune d'entre elles at on vu la femme
qui l'avait invité à faire le discours a
également proposé de lui prêter son
appartement
c'était un studio donc il n'y avait
qu'un solide elle lui a dit je ne serais
pas là tu peux dormir ici donc il a
pensé ok très bien mais les choses ne se
sont pas passées comme ça elle est
revenue plus tôt mais elle a voulu que
julien qui reste quand même
[Musique]
dans une des femmes lui faisait vraiment
d avance surtout la plus jeune il semble
qu'elle l'ait vu à la télé qu'elle soit
tombée amoureuse de lui peu importe ce
que ça veut dire c'est comme une groupie
d'un groupe de rock ou quelque chose
comme ça il fallait qu'elle l'approchent
et finalement elle y parvient aussi ils
ont une aventure d'une nuit mais à un
moment donné toute cette histoire s'est
résumée à la question du préservatif
comme sa boîte au crâne d'un bien non ce
n'est qu'après avoir appris qu'assange
avait couché avec les deux femmes que
celles ci ont décidé d'aller voir la
police
ce moment fut décisif pour wikileaks et
pour julian assange
c'est à cet instant que cette histoire a
pris une tournure très différentes
ces deux femmes sont allées à la police
mais pas pour signaler un viol elle
voulait que julian fasse un test de
dépistage du sida lorsqu'elle avait eu
des relations sexuelles non protégées
avec lui et cela les inquiétait jackson
par surdose donc il n'y a pas eu de
véritable viol il n'y a pas eu de
violence même si tous les journaux ont
ensuite écrit accusations de viol mais
il n'y a pas eu de viol il s'agissait de
rapports sexuels consentis
exactement exactement c'était le but de
tout l'exercice
il fallait que le mot viol soit utilisé
un rapport avec julian assange enquête
pour viol visant julian assange
fondateur de mort qui ont lieu le vison
tout lien assange fondateur de wikileaks
ange a été interrogé à ce sujet
d'accusations de viol accusations de
viol
mais les femmes qui l'accusent de
l'accusation de viol mais dans l'esprit
de beaucoup de gens il est quelque chose
de suspect de contraire à l'éthique chez
lui parce qu'il se dérober à la justice
je pense qu'il aurait mieux fait d'aller
en suède car c'était l'occasion pour lui
de blanchir son nom mais en même temps
je comprends parfaitement pourquoi il
n'a pas fait ça le problème avec la
suède et que je ne comprend pas la
langue de ce pays le climat médiatique
en suède est en outre assez hostile je
pense que si julienne était allé en
suède à ce moment là il aurait été
extradé extrait de la presse se moquer
souvent de lui et les gens disaient ah
il ne veut pas affronter les
conséquences en suède et ainsi de suite
on disait qu'il était paranoïaque mais
je pense qu'au regard de la situation
actuelle et maintenant nous savons que
les états unis ne pourchasse vraiment je
pense qu'elle n'a jamais était
paranoïaque
[Musique]
la grande histoire qui à mon avis a
vraiment saper le soutien public à
julian a été bien évidemment la sphère
suédoise des journaux de qualité et des
chaînes de télévision aussi se sont
montés contre julian de manière gratuite
[Musique]
il serait juste de dire que les médias
traditionnels n'ont jamais vraiment aimé
julian il n'aimait pas julienne parce
que son modèle de diffusion de
l'information était une menace à leur
existence
[Musique]
il avait beaucoup de jalousie dans les
médias traditionnels envers wikileaks
est en vert assange en particulier je
voudrais que pourquoi n'est-il pas plus
comme nous croient y est pourquoi ne
peut-il pas être l'un de nous
ils voulaient avoir accès aux documents
c'était les personnes les plus gentils
de la planète
désormais ils ne peuvent même pas montré
un peu de respect en couvrant son
affaire à une folle mais navarro crises
car demander en même temps il
collaborait avec lui il prenait les
informations qu'il avait mais ensuite
immédiatement disons le lendemain il y
avait un article à succès dans le new
york times écrit par bill keller qui
était rédacteur en chef à l'époque le
décrivant comme un vague air ridi qui
est kaduna plus que tourner autour de
son caractère c'est ce que je pense que
c'est une trahison
c'est une trahison de principe
[Musique]
que pensez-vous des allégations selon
lesquelles julian assange est je cite le
new york times 1 artistique avec une
vision des mesures et de sa propre
importance et qu'il ne s'intéresse pas
aux questions banales comme l'hygiène
personnelle mais elle est vraiment
je ne pense pas qu'il existe un autre
journaliste ou éditeurs ayant remporté
des prix internationaux importants en
matière de journalisme et qui aurait été
critiqué par des organisations
médiatiques parce que ses chaussettes
étaient sales ou parce qu'il ne s'était
pas laver les cheveux mais non
sérieusement je me demande si un être
humain a déjà été soumis à une telle
campagne de diffamation par le passé
c'était extraordinaire
[Musique]
m
en 2011 la justice britannique a ordonné
la libération d'assange sous caution à
condition qu'ils ne quittent pas le pays
il devait également ne pas quitter la
maison de campagne d'un proche
le journaliste britannique von smith
je suis assis ici sur une chaise dans
mon salon de ellingham hall et sociaux
cette maison est en quelque sorte le
produit de richesse que ma famille a
accumulé pendant des centaines d'années
ma famille a déménagé ici en 1795 et
j'ai la chance d'en avoir la
responsabilité
bonne semaine et s'anime bastide c'est
un journaliste d'investigation et un
journaliste de guerre qui nous a
gentiment faire ce vaste espace où nous
pouvions travailler sur nos publications
en toute sécurité
n'importe quelle chanson we made it vous
sentez vous en sécurité ici je me sens
en sécurité dans la mesure du possible
toujours un peu plus je me sentirais
plus en sécurité si j'étais ici et que
personne ne savait que j'étais ici
mais pour ce qui est de la maison et le
terrain il n'y a pas à se plaindre
en gros wikileaks a fait de cet espace
son bureau pour une période assez longue
si vous étiez venu ici vous auriez
trouvé des gens assis devant des
ordinateurs des pages imprimées et
traînaient partout et il se baladait
avec des petits disques comme ça cela
signifiait à voir avec nous julian et
les gens qui travaillaient pour lui cela
signifiait que tous les gens qui voulait
l'interviewer venait ici
mais ici c'était leur principal bureau
le siège de wikileaks
[Musique]
c'est aussi gac ultérieurement beaucoup
de travail a été accomplie je dirais que
les publications du québec gates ont été
préparé pendant que julian était en
résidence surveillée à ellingham hall
tout se faisait dans le plus grand
secret si vous aviez été là vous auriez
vu des gens devant leur ordinateur mais
vous n'auriez pas osé poser de questions
car à la moindre question
les gens vous regardent est à ce moment
là on se disait mais qu'elle est bête ma
question pourquoi je la pose il me le
dire s ils voulaient me le dire j'étais
là quand ils ont publié les journaux de
la guerre en afghanistan
je les observais travaillé sur les
documents diplomatiques je les ai vus se
pencher sur des choses qui sont apparus
plus tard il est intéressant de voir à
quel point il est difficile d'arrêter le
travail d'organisation comme wikileaks
wikileaks ne sera pas la dernière
même si elle disparaît et pour le moment
rien n'annonce que cela sera le cas
elle est devenue une sorte
d'organisation de guérilla pour la
liberté d'expression of speech
j'ai entendu pour la première fois que
julian se trouvait à l'ambassade
d'équateur le lendemain du jour où il
s'est rendu à cette ambassade
j'ai lu ça dans les journaux et je me
suis rendu compte que je venais de
perdre l'argent de la caution julian
assange s'est réfugié dans l'ambassade
d'équateur
monde et l'asile politique assange avait
l'équateur lui accorder l'asile
politique
le chef de wikileaks julian assange est
entrée dans la ma selle d'équateur bien
qu'il ait obtenu l'asile cela ne
signifie pas que s'ils tentent de
quitter l'ambassade il ne sera pas
arrêté par la police britannique y voilà
c'est l'ambassade équateur où julian
assange a vécu pendant près de sept ans
l'ambassade n'occupe qu'un des deux
appartement du premier étage flad lui
qui n'a regardé le balcon c'est le seul
balcon de l'ambassade
oui c'est ici que se trouve la pièce de
julian les cinq dernières années
assange le fondateur de wikileaks qui
refuse de quitter l'ambassade d'équateur
allons devrait faire son premier
commentaire public cet après midi je
suis ici aujourd'hui parce que je ne
peux pas être là avec vous wimille
cannabis fort nous nous connaissions
avant son arrivée à l'ambassade est en
fait les tic l'idée selon laquelle
l'équateur pouvait le protégé découler
de cette amitié rice l'intérim alors ce
qui c'était son dernier recours
craignez vous des sanctions locaux
auraient pris en main et nous avons le
il pourrait y avoir des représailles ce
qui serait terrible
vous ne pouvez vous imaginer le
précédent que ce serait si le royaume
uni donner suite à ces menaces et
faisait irruption dans notre ambassade
pour arrêter assange et dynamique
chinoise la asunta x
l'ambassade elle-même l'ambassade
équatorienne est petit c'est un
appartement
c'est un appartement de trois pièces
d'éoliennes quand il est arrivé à
occuper une pièce donc il avait une
moitié de la pièce pour dormir et
l'autre moitié pour diriger wikileaks ce
bâtiment est entouré de hauts bâtiments
de tous les côtés as not alright for
death ne laissant pas la lumière du jour
y pénétrer
julian comparer son séjour à l'ambassade
ses jours dans un vaisseau spatial et
koffi raskin l'évolué que dans la
lumière artificielle
il ne voyageait vers le soleil ils ne
pouvaient pas obtenir des soins
dentaires des soins médicaux
il y avait d'énormes défis
les cinq premières années il était tout
le temps sous surveillance la barre une
sorte de surveillance ouverte et quand
on se trouvait à l'ambassade
on entendait constamment les gens à
l'extérieur qui parlait par talkie
walkie il n'y avait presque pas
d'endroit dans l'ambassade où on n'était
pas surveillée dans les bâtiments
environnants
ils avaient installé des caméras vidéo
l'ont porté dirigé sur l'ambassade
et soit ça a été l'endroit le plus
surveillées au monde pendant de
nombreuses années
julian assange a continué de diriger
wikileaks depuis l'ambassade d'équateur
pendant toutes ces années qu'il a
passées entre ses murs beaucoup de
nouvelles publications et révélations
ont vu le jour les plus importantes ont
probablement été publiés en 2016 l'année
des élections présidentielles aux états
unis
[Musique]
et plus
les gens ne veulent qu'une chose rendre
sa grandeur à l'amérique
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de gens qui
pensaient que julian assange avait fait
élire trump est ce parce qu'il avait
rendu public ce qu'on appelle les 10èmes
cilic ce qu'on vous dit il s'agit des
emails du parti démocrate
cm il révélait comment le conseil
national démocrate avait fait de son
mieux pour remplacer bernie sanders
procure la le candidat le plus populaire
par hillary clinton comme candidate à
l'élection présidentielle
et c'était là quelque chose qui je pense
a choqué le public américain qui est
vraiment importance concernant wikileaks
c'est que le gouvernement russe a
espionné les américains puis les ordonné
ces informations à wikileaks pour
qu'elles soient publiées sur internet
nous avons appris quelque chose
concernant quelqu'un se faisant appeler
du sifer 2.0 d'autres fuites sur la
partie démocratique et divers moyens qui
étaient censés nous convaincre que ces
informations provenaient de la russie eh
bien je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si
c'était la russie je ne sais pas d'où tu
julian a reçu ces fuites
julian ne me l'a jamais dit julian dit
que ce n'était pas les russes on nous
interprètent de façon erronée comme si
nous voulions porter préjudice à hillary
clinton
comme si je voulais porter préjudice à
hillary clinton comme si je ne l'aimé
pas c'est faux
[Musique]
doris quand ils ont révélé ces faits
concernant hillary toute cette
hypocrisie et sert à tout le monde s'est
dit bon ce n'est pas si grave mais quand
elle a perdu les élections tout le monde
a dit oh mon dieu c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle a perdu parce qu'ils
avaient besoin d'explications explosif
et la façon dont ces publications ont
été perçues a été terrible il y avait
tellement de colère et de haine mais qui
m'ont arrêté le arrêter le arrêté julian
assange sur telus de l'ambassade
faites le taire réduisez le au silence
acquis
même les années ont passé la situation
devenait de plus en plus difficile la
pression devenait de plus en plus grande
et puis d'un coup le gouvernement
équatorien a changé je pense que la
situation est devenue vraiment compliqué
il ya eu des élections en équateur à
et les lignes moreno est devenu
président et c'était un grand partisan
des états unis il l'est toujours au
monde
le nouveau gouvernement a décidé de
réorienter la politique étrangère
équatorienne il a décidé d'avoir des
relations différentes avec les états
unis ce texte
josiane était un obstacle à cela que je
n'ai jamais été d'accord avec les
agissements de julian assange
je n'ai jamais accepté l'idée de lire
les mails privés des gens pour obtenir
des informations
même si ces informations peuvent servir
à exposer des actes indésirables commis
par des gouvernements ou des citoyens on
ne fait pas ce genre de choses le
gouvernement de moreno était déterminé à
se débarrasser de lui transformé sa vie
en enfer on interdisait aux avocats
d'entrée aux fouilles et les visiteurs
ont installé des caméras dans chaque
pièce et rendez vous privé devait avoir
lieu dans les toilettes
on ne lui donnait pas de papier toilette
chaque geste cruel on ne lui donnait pas
de papier toilette non juste on oubliait
sadr ainsi dire on oublié lui apporter
de la nourriture de lui apporter du lait
cil oublié de lui apporter de la
nourriture qu est ce que cela impliquait
qu'il ne mangeait pas
[Musique]
monsieur assange je pense que nous
savons tous est un problème dont nous
avons hérité je dois poser cette
question car selon les employés de
l'entreprise de sécurité embauchés par
le gouvernement équatorien julian était
lui-même un locataire extrêmement
difficile il se serait en particulier
beaucoup disputés avec le personnel de
l'ambassade
il aurait négligé son hygiène
personnelle laissant souvent la salle de
bain et la petite cuisine en désordre
[Musique]
c'était au cours des 18 mois du
gouvernement moreno ce nouveau parler
c'est vrai mais pourquoi n'y at il rien
de tout cela au cours de six années
précédentes at-il sedan changer de
personnalité
[Musique]
ils vont accuser d'étaler des excréments
sur les murs
ce qui est fou c'est un mensonge ce
n'est pas vrai times prouvent
il leur fallait des preuves des raisons
de le virer de lui retirer son asile
ce qui est vraiment un scandale
humanitaire international en tant
qu'humain aujourd'hui j'annonce que le
comportement irrespectueux et agressive
de monsieur julien assange nous a mis
dans une situation où l'asile de
monsieur assange ne peut plus bénéficier
de soutiens et n'est plus viable
[Musique]
les sponsors c'était la première fois
que je le voyais en dix ans et j'ai vu
l'effet que cela avait eu sur lui
c'était comme j'étais sous le choc short
et vous
[Musique]
si on remonte à 2011 vous savez il était
tellement jeune dynamique agréable il
plaisantait c
alors vous savez le voir après dix-huit
mois de torture seuls les
sept ans d'enfermement être traînés par
sept policiers
sam
palisson
il avait l'air très vieux - plus du tout
jeune
reste fort julian nous nous battrons
pour toi
nous ne laisserons pas te faire ça reste
fort souviens toi de sa n'oublie pas
reste fort tu seras libre
[Musique]
les etats unis sont immédiatement
transmis au royaume uni une demande
d'extradition
mais cette demande ne pouvait pas être
prise en considération avant que julian
assange ne purge ses 11 mois de prison
pour avoir violé les conditions de sa
résidence surveillée en 2012
lorsqu'il s'est réfugié dans l'ambassade
d'équateur le fondateur de wikileaks a
alors été envoyée à la prison de
belmarsh près de londres
la prison de belmarsh où est détenu
monde julian est une prison de haute
sécurité de sécurité maximale et lacs
sont emprisonnés des meurtriers des
terroristes des poseurs de bombes des
gens violents
[Musique]
hermach presse samedi que la prison de
belmarsh et même pire que celle de
guantanamo et on lui refuse le droit de
fraterniser avec d'autres prisonniers
il m'a dit qu'en voyant des gens
passaient devant sa cellule car il ne
souhaitait que pouvoir leur parler
et ce en danse l'ict vidéo j'ai vu ces
vidéos qui ont fuité et dans lesquels
ils semblent avoir perdu beaucoup de
poids quand j'ai vu ça je ne suis
vraiment mise à pleurer parce que quand
vous connaissez très bien quelqu'un et
que vous le voyez dans une telle
situation
mieux le nord là vous n'êtes pas
autorisés à les faire passer quoi que ce
soit la seule façon de communiquer avec
le monde extérieur pour lui et de
recevoir des lettres la chasse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous ne savions pas si à 100 je voulais
communiquer avec des journalistes
voulaient voici la lettre que nous
venons de recevoir de la prison de
belmarsh et elle nous vient de julian
assange comme on peut le lire au dos de
cette lettre cette lettre révèle son
désespoir et sa frustration à mesure que
le procès approche le fondateur de
wikileaks dit qu'il n'a pas accès à
internet ou au téléphone ce qui entrave
sérieusement sa capacité à préparer sa
propre défense et qui n'a pas grand
chose à faire à part tourner en rond des
milliers de fois par jour dans sa
cellule
c'est très pénible c'est de voir
quelqu'un avec qui vous avez travaillé
et qui est un vieil ami et ne savent pas
se trouver face à un tel danger que sa
personne soit fasse un tel danger
penser qu'il est possible qu'il ne s'en
sortent pas et tout à fait bouleversant
[Musique]
radieuse les accusations que le
gouvernement américain a porté contre
julian pour l'extrader ont radicalement
changé
au début ils l'ont accusé de piratage
informatique et d'avoir aidé manning à
obtenir les informations que ce dernier
voulait manning était un jeune homme qui
faisait partie des forces armées aient
été clairement choqué par ce qui se
passait autour de lui
bradley manning désormais chelsea
manning et ce lanceur d' alerte qui a
fourni à wikileaks leurs informations
les plus importantes
les journaux de guerre afghans la vidéo
du meurtre des journalistes de reuters
des papiers diplomatique tout cela a été
fournie par bradley manning
selon le département américain de la
justice
julian assange n'a pas seulement reçu
des données de son informateur
ceci ne constituerait pas un crime
les journalistes ont le droit d'acquérir
des documents auprès de leurs sources
même s'il s'agit de documents
confidentiels mais du point de vue du
gouvernement américain assange a
comploté avec le soldat manning qui l'a
aidé à accéder à ses informations
confidentielles dans l'intention de
nuire aux états unis les états unis
veulent prouver qu assange n'est pas un
journaliste mais un espion
et fine de 14,2 ces accusations si on y
pense pourrait être parfaitement
applicable à d'autres publications de
journalistes ou de médiapart dans quelle
chance
[Musique]
si julian assange en tant qu'éditeur et
mis en prison pour le fait d'être un
éditeur pour aucune autre raison que
d'être un éditeur
alors il n'y a pas de règles il n'y a
pas de règle du jeu
[Musique]
said aux états unis tout journaliste
devrait avoir froid dans le dos face aux
accusations portées contre cet éditeur
ils pourraient être les prochains à être
visés triplex
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dr julian sher julian tu es l'une des
personnes les plus courageuses que je
connaisse
et cette phrase que tu répétais souvent
le courage est contagieux est vraiment
très juste chaud c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'importants mouvements de
contestation surgissent il ya je crois
des millions de personnes qui te
souhaite et comprennent que ce qui est
en jeu est très important il n'est pas
seul il n'est pas seul un grand nombre
de personnes apprécient ce qu'il a fait
quand tu aimes dans l'intérêt du public
[Musique]
elle lui même adulé one by one je me
souvenir de toi julian quand tu n'étais
pas encore aussi célèbre quand tu étais
relativement libre et je me souviens de
ce petit sac à dos que tu portais et de
la vie très humble que tu mener
j'attends avec impatience le jour où il
sera libre et où il ne sera pas
surveillées ni poursuivis par les
américains dans le monde entier
[Musique]
j'espère que nous serons te sortir de là
que tu seras assis à côté de nous dans
un endroit agréable quelque part où il
fait chaud au bord de la mer et tout
cela ne sera qu'un mauvais souvenir
[Musique]
non
il ya beaucoup de choses pour lesquelles
nous devons le remercier
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]